اسماء عالميه اعلنت تمردها على قرارات
الملياردير الامريكيه الذي قرر معاقبه من
يتخلف عن دفع رسوم الاشتراك من مستخدمي
منصه تويتر بازاله علامه التحقق بالفعل
مؤسسات كبيره وشهيره رفضت الامر بينها
البيت الابيض وصحيفه نيويورك تايمز التي
اعلنت انها لن تدفع مقابل اشتراكات تويتر
او التحقق من حسابات المنظمه الخاصه جاء
ذلك بعدما كشفت منصه عن برنامج يفرض على
الشركات والمؤسسات اشتراكا شهريا قدر الف
دولار كي يحصلوا على العلامه الموثقه الا
وهي عباره عن شارات ذهبيه للعلامات
التجاريه والشركات ورماديه للحكومات بينما
اوضحت دراسه استقصائيه اجريت نوفمبر على
300 متخصص في التسويق والاعلان وجدوا ان
53% قالوا انهم من غير المرجح ان يدفعوا
80 دولارات شهريا للتحقق على تويتر